not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah's book like you've
never had before
so so so what we're just saying guys in
a nutshell and it was lovely
thank you thank you for your time
but what i'm saying is one thing that
i'll ask you guys is
great of god thank you ask him if you're
there guide me
that's all it takes i'm telling you one
thing that can change your life
it's you won't lose anything god
almighty if you are there
guide me you've got nothing to lose
maybe to your youtubers
yeah sisters thank you very much for
your time it was a pleasure thank you
sure yes look at this look at this watch
you see that design there let's have a
look okay look a bit closer yeah
i know what that means you see the
design look behind it
touch his hand oh basically the
opposite genders for example respect
because you know look if you think about
it you know you've had this whole
uh issues in the workplace for example
touching a woman's knee
yeah no no in the workplace now in the
workplace now they say that you even
have to keep the door open
because a lot of women feel
uncomfortable when a man is talking to
you and it starts touching your knee
like in
a sexual way but maybe she doesn't want
to be touched so what islam says
prevention is better than cure
because i have respect for the opposite
gender and i'm married
um the only way i can touch the agenda
yeah there's nothing that symbolizes it
but i tell the person i'm married so the
thing is our respect for the opposite
gender
because we honor them like when i was
referring to you i was friends with your
sisters yeah
why because i have respect for you i'm
not i don't want you to feel as if i'm
talking to chat you up
because because i've been i believe and
this is and this is really important
because i believe society
society has really sexualized women to a
point where any kind of discussion is
all sexual
all of it why does it have to be like
that even as muslim men we are taught to
lower our gays for example if i'm
walking down the road and i see a woman
dressed up in a certain way i have to
look the other way out of respect
so i believe today we've lost that
because women have been sexualized
objectified the beauty the beauty
industry has made you feel so ugly why
you guys are all beautiful in your own
way why do you have to feel
and look a certain way so what we say is
islam islam has come to honor a woman
to a status where you are a human being
you have your intellect to offer
not just your body parts whatever it may
be so that's the reason when it comes to
the question of shaking the hands
out of respect that i believe you have a
wife
a husband